دخول [موسيقى] أجنبية
إلى عالم القرن الثامن عشر
للاحتفال بالعام القمري الجديد
المناسب لإمبراطور
هنا في متحف قصر هونغ كونغ ،
يمكن للزوار تجربة كيف احتفل تشينلونغ ، أحد
أباطرة الصين الأطول حكمًا ،
بالعطلة التي
سأصفها  الاحتفال القمري
باعتباره سيمفونية للتعداد
أه تعلم أنه لا يتعلق الأمر
بمعرفة ما تراه من الأشياء الرائعة ولكن
عليك أيضًا أن تتخيل ما قد
يسمعه الإمبراطور وعائلته ما
قد يتذوقونه وما نوع الأشياء التي
قد يلمسونها وماذا  هي العطور التي
ستشتمها ، فعلينا حقًا أن نستخدم
كل حواسنا لتخيل ما حدث
قبل 300 عام داخل مدينة محظورة ،
كل كائن معروض تم
تصميمه بدقة من
قِبل الإمبراطور نفسه ، وإذا نظرت
عن كثب ، فهي مليئة بالمعاني الميمونة
كل شيء له معنى خفي ، على
سبيل المثال ، إذا نظرت إلى مزهرية جميلة ،
فهذا يعني قطعة لأن ping و ping
صحيحان ، فإن طابع المزهرية له
نفس التخصيص مع شخصية
السلام ،
وأطنان رموز الخصوبة أيضًا ،
ولكن أيضًا قرع القرع  يحتوي على
العديد من البذور وأيضًا القرع معروف
في الصين باسم Hulu وله
نطق مشابه مع كلمات الثروة
والميمونة
واحدة من القطع البارزة في المعرض هي
رداء تنين ملكي من الحرير القرمزي
وخيط ذهبي حقيقي لزي مهرجان
الإمبراطور  والإمبراطور فقط
ولكن هناك العديد من تقاليد العطلات
من القصر الإمبراطوري التي لا تزال
تمارس حتى اليوم مثل الاستخدام الزخرفي
للزهور الملونة والرمزية
وكذلك زخارف الجدران المعلقة التي
تحمل رسائل ميمونة آمل أن
يأتي الكثير من الزوار
ويربطون هذه الأشياء حقًا  الأشياء القديمة
بحياتهم الشخصية اليوم
السنة الصينية الجديدة هي أهم عطلة في الصين
وأيضًا واحدة من أكثر الأوقات ازدحامًا
للسفر في هونغ كونغ التي
تحملت حتى وقت قريب بعضًا من
أصعب القيود المرغوبة في العالم ،
تعد العطلة دفعة مطلوبة بشدة
لزوار قطاع السياحة  هل يمكن المغامرة
داخل المبنى الجديد الذي تبلغ تكلفته 450 مليون دولار ،
وهو كنز دفين من الآثار أكثر
من 900 على سبيل الإعارة من
المدينة المحرمة في بكين ، وكلها دعوة للاكتشاف في
عام الأرنب كريستي لوستل
سي إن إن هونغ كونغ